la côte d'azur avec son soleil et ses
plages elle reste la première
destination des étrangers en vacances en
france
un tourisme tout public et à tous les
prix anis japonais dépensier et
hollandais économe se partagent la
promenade des anglais
mais la vraie nouveauté c'est l'arrivée
des nouveaux riches venus de russie
l'argent c'est pas un problème pour nous
je pense qu'on va dépenser 5000 $ ici
combien de jours faute quatre jours pour
les commerçants niçois ou 97 est un bon
cru
les magasins de souvenirs se frotte les
mains les japonais peuvent dépenser
jusqu'à 700 francs en cinq minutes
c'est bien par rapport à ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a connu les années précédentes
il ya quand même ça bouge un peu plus
les genres dépense un peu plus les
hôtels comme les résidences de vacances
affiche complet jusqu'à la fin du mois
pour les tour opérateurs étrangers
la côte d'azur reste une valeur sûre
mais elle se visite au pas de course
les séjours sont de plus en plus courts
même pour un mois d'août où généralement
on avait l'habitude des fins de recevoir
des personnes pour trois semaines quinze
jours minimum
il en a énormément de passage autre
raison de ce succès les campagnes
lancées auprès des commerçants pour un
meilleur accueil
les français ont la réputation d'être
arrogant et malpoli pour que 98 soit
meilleur que 97 il faudra encore faire
des efforts touché au pubis cécélès le
mans le mans en français aussi tu as
fini le petit peu